we've Kristen Bell coming in yes you
okay what is she promoting she's going
to be in the new film ship what's that
based on the TV series chips what's that
yes where they took my name her how
about some cake for the chip on her
husband Dax Shepard and Michael Pena are
well there's that they're there I
haven't got no money yet what's that
with the movies called chin I bought
some cake front of chip off you're going
to go with my name are you gonna get
through this one I'm a little take on
spitting all this yeah walk walk and
shut off so glad you have your own
microphone yeah you'll meet both soccer
what does that mean somebody called me a
sick Kaka on Instagram typos I think
that's the was really last
oh he's going to bring her in bring in
something I bet Roland
welcome Kristen Bell hi Kristen how are
you good good
Jim didn't turn your microphone on hold
on a second you didn't tell me to okay I
thought it would be obvious when I
walked in my pants I know I know but I
want to give you a second because a lot
of times people blurt things out when
they walk in I wanted you to have a
moment to know that we were actually on
the air what kind of things do they blur
it out maybe we hit on the understand no
but tell me never happened one where you
have so many people walk in oh I didn't
know we were on unless they want to stay
in [ __ ] like hey oh my coach my co-star
suck oh no we're on so you are talking
about my coaster they really blow yeah
well welcome to the show thanks for
having me yeah happy with us before I
don't think I'm nothing a long time ago
yeah I think if we promote Veronica Mars
yes yes yes and that was like five years
ago
yeah that was a while back I mean I
would say that a fact that your husband
is your co-star in this movie you're
probably not going to come on the air in
[ __ ] because now my carotid also
I like him very much
hugest person on the planet to me so
yeah did you meet working were you guys
doing a film how'd you beat no we met at
a like a dinner party for a friend of
like ten people and had no connection he
was like I don't know who that girl is
and I just remember he talked so much
and then we ran into each other two
weeks later at a Red Wings game and we
were like oh weren't you at Shauna's
birthday party and then he just started
flirting with me and I remember he
took my gum because he said give me more
gum and I said no just this and I kind
of like pulled it out of my mouth and he
grabbed it and I was like oh my god this
guy wants to [ __ ] me and what it means
if you take someone's gum that's a
hundred percent yeah you really want
them those are clear well that's great
yeah what ball is to do that you got to
look like - effort to do that yeah Jim
took a half-eaten Altoid for me once but
that's just third base times I didn't
know that's not all that good
serious is coming so when you said he
talked about when you first met yeah you
know that did you like that or your talk
slow you do know I love it I love it
because he has opinions on everything
but their well thought out but he also
has this like he talks a lot but he has
this very I don't know evolved way of
sensing whether or not his opinions are
wanted or can add to the to the like
conversation so he just pull back a lot
like he can be quiet you know but he's
just he's a very very strong critical
thinker he studied anthropology he has a
primatology degree so he's like citing
all these things about why we're like
monkeys and why humans relate to each
other he's very it's very sexy listen to
him talk yeah it's amazing have you ever
dated somebody and in general like we
did you said every time they talk in
front of people you like shut up
I would never date someone where I
thought I wanted a photo I have that
ever happened really times dating them
that's not the person you should date
it's not long-term relation like
somebody you go out with a couple of
times kind of like them and you know
them but you don't rescue physically
very yet it all in a drink yeah they get
drunk and sound stupid we don't know
they tip a few back and all the sudden I
act yeah that's real talking about yeah
not that no he's not but I mean have you
ever in your life had someone proud no
because I have I like I've had three or
four very long-term relationships like
over two years two to five years but
beyond that I do like one date and I
know like I know if I'm going to be able
to tolerate you or if you're like a if
you if we can sink
closer hango yeah you feel pressure to
be like a good couple because I feel
like you cause like my wife for instance
like loves you as a couple I think a lot
of like especially women love you too as
a couple so if you start showing any
chinks in the arm
just could be terrible for both of you
well here's why first of all yes I do
feel I feel not a pressure but a
responsibility but my listen my
worldview is this particularly now when
Earth is in such a bad mood it is
important to spread joy period I like my
husband very much we're very open about
our relationship on purpose
because we used to be very like tethered
to all the details and we were like this
is our private life and then I thought
you know what we talked about the fact
that we go to couples therapy or that we
fight we don't fight this morning we
literally have fight before we got here
did you guys fight about um he my that
person he was doing my hair walked in
and she said did you get my text and he
goes she'll never text back she but she
doesn't text back and I go excuse me I
do text back he said no you don't then
pulled his phone out evidenced a lot of
times I didn't text back and I felt
stupid and I felt like it was a
defamatory remark I was like it's I do
text back I just don't not tethered to
my phone all the time I didn't check it
that morning I just felt like he was
insulting me and we argued about it but
the thing is we argue in a healthy way
we just communicate you know in a lot of
arguments almond yes he says a critical
thing he's a very fast thinker and it
drives me crazy but the good thing is he
knows that I'll cry it goes too far so
you go to a so he does have some
performance but we're very honest about
the fact that we because we disagree on
99% of things in the world in the world
but we argue really well we go to
therapy to try to get a bigger toolbox
to communicate and it makes us happier
and healthier how long you merge we've
been married three years and together
for 10 I'm this is this is not long did
he say oh he didn't mention I asked him
he said you've only been serious for a
year and a half I don't know what you
did just seeing each other oh my god you
brought that this is a you had a
fascination with us with the sloth and
this is why I match I saw a video of a
girl who got a sloth brought to her and
I know that HAP that we got you in the
video or no it didn't say you I think I
would have recognized that it was
somebody else did she have like a panic
attack on the bed was she no and over
her face like that's crying
not on the bed this was in an office
setting I think could you go could I
didn't know that you had done oh that
girl is
began to my style because I definitely
had a panic attack when he knows that's
what I'm thinking of okay but mine is
even worse I was not like dressed in
real clothes and had makeup on like this
girl
Dax basically I used to Google at night
like all these cute baby sloths because
I love them I just think they're like a
monkey and a pig with the reflexes of
your grandmother look how cute it says
on my tinder profile and she got he
actually got a like a company that does
animals for movies to come to the house
and bring one to set like a little like
habitat in the living room for a couple
hours so I could interact with it and he
had to take out a wild animal
sure inspector making it was like the
best present ever and he said go wait in
the back bedroom with the dogs while
your present gets here you'll never
guess what it is and I was like well I
know it's on a handbag and then she
walked down the hallway and I was
already crying on the bed when you came
in because I just felt it I knew it I
don't know how I knew it but I knew he
brought a sloth to the house and I
basically was sobbing sobbing sobbing on
the bed and he videotaping what is it
about this animal because the other girl
reacted the same way she just broke down
what is it about the time well that
makes people cry when they I don't look
like a nice animal solely because I
think particularly for girls they just
look like they're cuddle bugs and
they're not really which is weird
because they're solitary animals but
they they look like they need you I
think maybe they're solitary animals
because they don't know like how great
cuddling is that's true well they like
cuddling with the trees but when you
like when you rescue out there it is
right when you when they rescue from
like a baby and they think that you are
the tree that's when it really ones
people just have lost like hanging from
their necks but you know what that's not
the exotic animal trade is not great
they don't bite them right they will
bite absolutely they're vampire teeth
but they go for you like this oh yeah
sorry sorry so it's going to take six or
seven minutes for them to make contact
you can probably move out a bit or throw
a fist up it just a just meet them with
an uppercut you're not really in that
much danger so what did you do with it
when you first walk in and see this
sloth did you did you walk over and pet
it do they say be careful what would you
do
well for a while I just cried on the bed
and then I think what happened was I put
I got very very nervous and my
adrenaline started going crazy I was
like in my pajamas and I put deodorant
on immediately because I was like kind
of no yes nothing it's like there we go
I was having this panic attack and I was
so excited and then I went out and they
like they give you this little stick and
you can feed it like bananas and melon
and then you can touch its fur which is
like a brillo pad and then they just
teach you all about the animal and like
hung in our living room on this like
makeshift habitat where it was like it
was hanging on with a ladder Wow pretty
incredible gift that is what a great
gift yeah I watch a book on sloths yeah
ritual not a shepherd yeah Jack Shepherd
that probably made you love him to be
like wow this guy really on that
animation people don't understand about
this lost video is that yes half of that
here's where I'm going to get deodorant
but I cut this part out of the video but
um basically I was excited to meet the
slob but I was also so overwhelmed but
the man I loved had gotten it to come to
the house
first of all found a sloth where do you
even find one and then taken out a wild
animal insurance e policy which I ensure
inspire I sound out later which I
thought was so funny it's a pretty
incredible gesture it really but it
helps like it I feel like like he must
have used some kind of Hollywood
connection I know he called an anti I
couldn't I wouldn't know how to do that
no no yeah you would cuz you would ask
like hey when you have a giraffe in a
movie who do you call you know ask
Google Oh always ask cool everything is
a statement mask is a joke that was a
boring statement it was correct when did
you guys what did you guys start going
into couples therapy like early yeah
very because we fought like oh my god we
bought so much when we first started
dating it was because there was problems
but you were like we correct would
there's potential here yeah we weren't
like perfect and I'm like let's also go
to cut we're not like crazy
we're not Stepford Wives but we were
fighting a lot because again we disagree
on everything but there was such an
intense attraction there was also this
trust despite the fact that we disagreed
so much and we were like you know what
we're not we
don't do well in the gladiator ring that
is our house we need to go to have
someone mediate this so that we can both
be told when we need to take
responsibility who's normally who's
normally the aggressor in the fight
light like is it you usually picking him
or him usually go hey you don't do this
it's both it's definitely both because
we're big on personal responsibility in
our family like you don't get a weight
you can't just like do anything without
getting called out for it like if you're
rude to someone you apologize we also
make sure that we apologize in front of
our kids so I think the problem with
like raising kids now is that like
people fight then everyone goes to bed
and the kids never see it so if we do
have any so any tension in the air
because I'm not like we fight in front
of our kids but if there's any tension
in the air the next morning we always
make sure we go like hey daddy I'm
really sorry that I was snippy with you
last night so the kids see it so they
see you apologize yeah I try we went to
a couple of therapies maybe like two
years ago and it was only a couple of
times because every time we would go and
the therapist would side with me at all
my wife would get various with her and
act like she was being ganged up on like
this isn't healthy we can't go to
therapy anymore we assign a different
therapist that well we just wanted it
out that's why now yeah yeah I just
realized this is going to be an in-house
situation that needs great worked out
everything works I don't like fault
anyone that doesn't go but I'm just
saying don't have a stigma about going
if you feel like you need it because I
look at it like you have a little
toolbox when you're born and it gets a
little bit bigger as you communicate
with other humans and if you wanted to
get really big and learn how to get
along with everyone you go to therapy
when did you discover the film the room
she wistfully remembers a long time ago
probably 15 years ago when I was for the
first season of Veronica Mars so 2004
were you are you at all involved in the
disaster artist a.m. yes because that's
what I was talking to Jim I was like
earlier this week and I was reading all
the articles from South by Southwest and
everything and I think I'm not even
involved in the motion picture community
and this is the first time a film has
come out that I'm bummed out that I'm
not somehow yea involved yeah just
because it's incredible this even
happening it's the best and there's so
many good real-life stories from it I
mean just it's it's an exceptional piece
of celluloid
incredible yeah and I've seen it I don't
know probably 20 or 30 times now and I'm
so happy that it's going to get a bigger
platform I hope that the disaster artist
will make people want to go back and
watch I've never seen it I went online I
watched moments of it it's really
entertaining I see why people like if
I've never seen the whole thing all the
way through it is such an experience if
you took the five best filmmakers in the
world right now
you know like Steven Spielberg Gus Van
Sant Dax Shepard all the really good
filmmakers and said do everything wrong
in a movie everything wouldn't even be
in the same universe yeah me wouldn't
come close no you've seen in theaters
right oh yeah yeah good night showing
yeah yeah I went to one with the Greg
Sestero put on and he got to do like his
and then he does a reading from the
original script and the original script
is even worse than the movie like the
dialogue in the script is worse than the
movie so it's so special yeah I've been
midnight screening where Tommy took his
shirt off I supposed to ask you if
you've met Tommy yeah I had him up here
you can I talked him for an hour he's
incredible he's incredible one problem I
had with I saw a clip of the film I saw
a little clip where they where they're
going to go up and make love in the
beginning really way too soon they're
always like about to go up and make
laughs yeah but then the other weird kid
comes in denne denne denne
and the guys laughing okay like yeah I
want to be alone that was like it was
really inappropriate emotion I can't
figure out if this little kid Danny
first we can figure I didn't anyone a
little kid or if he's a teenager we
can't figure out angling for it I know
nothing has this pillow fight on the bed
with them it's so like when aliens make
movies about humans is what comes out
this is what's made oh this is how
humans interact right there's just a
disconnect from the entire space yes yes
correct music very weird
it was no but it's so enjoyable I would
like to see it all the way through I
just have not had the chance I got to be
honest some of the active is a bit
lackluster what's so great about it
because it's still sincere it's just ah
God I didn't say anything you know what
again I'm going someone to see little
teeny clips I almost didn't want to blow
it I was gonna watch something and they
said major spoilers I'm like no I want
to I want to enjoy this beginning to end
without really know I don't know how
that you know nothing that matters but
you don't know key plot points
I mean for fun just to watch it you will
have such a blast watching it or just
get stoned and watching it's so
wonderful it really is great have you
did you read the book before you did the
moon no I wish that I had I had a who
toddlers I count a lot of time to read
books get a book on tape yeah like you
get a book on tape Drake's Estero does a
very good book on tape no I'd rather see
it then read the book after no yeah yeah
yeah definitely I'd like to read the
book after that's just me this way I
learn more about people instead of
looking at the book is about the movie
so yeah you want to know the movie so
when you first see the room did you get
it immediately are you like what
everyone does Sarah no no no I knew it
because it was given to me by the
creator of veronica mars rob thomas who
I think had gotten it from Paul Rudd but
that like he was just he handed it to me
and he was like this is a gift and I was
like okay and I trust him implicitly and
I put it in and I've never been the same
you know as I was telling him earlier
the it's shot it was shot twice you know
shot on digital another film filmed and
so Tommy's in here and he gave me a copy
of the room on blu-ray and I was like
Tommy because there's it shot on HD and
on film and all anybody's ever seen it's
the film and I go this is blu-ray so
this must be the HD and he goes no it's
upgraded film and I think we he do shot
the thing on HD why wouldn't you use
that and he goes this is better he's the
bestest that made sense I'm sorry
maybe the HD had some color correction
problems or whenever he's ever even seen
the footage it's very special I hardly
overspent on that film a little bit
eight million bucks it was not the best
budget management no no probably not the
best budget management mmm-hmm how would
you know what is a really good film tip
what's I directed by my husband oh yeah
I didn't director that is really and
directed it now did he did he get the
gig first and then say he wanted you in
it or how did you both wind up in it I
well he's a I was sleeping with the
writer and the director and I had
another party and Tom I just say I had
an adjustable ratios appetite but he I
said can I be in it while he was writing
it and then he said yeah then he wrote
it then he sat me down and said I'm
really hesitating on casting you and
this was dead serious so I was like oh
my god I felt like I was going to
cry and he said you're just too um
likable and I can't have Karen be
likable at all so you really really
really really need to be unlikable and a
[ __ ] just be like vapid and like no one
wants to be around you and I was like I
can do that and then he actually had me
read the sides with him he liked that
why did you how much better that makes
me feel I've never just got the movie
handed to me yeah no nobody's discovered
in an airport and no that doesn't happen
those are all myth I know I guess so
yeah well I was a soda jerk huge people
still audition like my audition for
everything I was as an audition once and
it obviously was a Luke Poisson movie I
did not get the part but I saw Domenici
niece was in there reading for obviously
a different part and Jo wha how do you
penally I never know how to say his name
yeah J pants he was in there reading
these guys still have to go out
everybody dude will you make me see
within here complaining about reading an
audition for seven people who don't
audition it's like Tom Cruise Tom Cruise
and the other ones I Tom Hanks another
Tom Hanks formerly do not have to
audition but I heard for Woody Allen
everybody reads and you all make
scale-like with Woody it's like if you
want to work woody you do this if you
don't you don't
Disney is as well waiting with Disney
everybody reads and everybody makes Gil
Wow really so everyone has to go through
an audition with it even Tom Cruise we
have to read her I would say yeah I mean
listen well here's here's the other
perspective and well how I look at it
for my husband's point of view you are
the director it doesn't matter if this
person is a body of work that you've
seen you want to know that they're going
to fit seamlessly into your vision you
want to know that they're going to give
you and be moldable the way that you
need them to so I actually don't have a
problem auditioning for things because I
think the director deserves that like
the writer deserves to have their words
said and not have any pitter patter
around all of them and not learn them
correctly like they do have that
position you deserve to see it you're
not making scale for the sequel to
frozen are you and I certainly hope not
yes that's kind of a proven like thing I
hope not yeah yeah you don't have to
audition again no I think I do have the
part at this point you've got it so you
have a nice when you do something like
frozen and it's so successful do you go
like this why
for the birds yes going in my
jammie-jams and voices over and it's
like I'm every kid in America loves me
yeah well I mean I don't like my goal
wasn't to get all the kids to love me
but it's not terrible but I did always
want to be a Disney princess and it just
sort of weirdly fell into my lap I had
auditioned for Rapunzel and not gotten
it and then they called me back in and
said we want to talk to you about this
other movie and so it was just you know
it was out of the rejection blossomed
frozen right and this is obviously much
bigger filming Rapunzel who's talking
about pretty bad I'm a prim great you
know I've been busy Anais are you it's
really good actually
I do love though that to complement
frozen you had to just trash Rapunzel I
was in trash you know I was only saying
that frozen was it was a massive self
have you seen either what's that no I
[ __ ] I'm from the Gregory Hines school
of entertainers and you're promoting
chips yeah which is in theaters this
Friday starring your son and Michael
Pena what he's doing my favorite film is
that big crash crash family if you don't
like crash out there your adult Michael
Pena was in that he played the I guess
the the guy who fixed doors whatever he
was the repairman yeah he was so I know
what everything isn't he's like an
ant-man this year and in collateral
beauty like heat Michael Pena has a part
in everything he's in a wrinkle in time
like he yep do you kids watch frozen uh
so rarely but sometimes yeah they know
it's you
yes okay so they didn't from your voice
yes but they don't care they don't ah
you are made to reject everything your
parents do that's in our DNA yeah they
don't care everything at home they shut
me down right quick are you a good
singer I think so welcome I mean I'm a
decent I'm a passable singer yeah you
ever want to sing professionally I mean
I don't know what versions of music I
know that but there's nice people of
those I wanted to sing within the
context of performing like I never
wanted to have an album or anything I
don't I don't have the drive to like
write my own music but I wanted to sing
as an actor and wish I could say that
this is such a fun thing to do and you
really don't put yourself there alright
Sam always talked me up I don't know
what to do and it isn't theaters a
Friday it's so weird that you worked
your home was there any fights on the
set about you and where you got a long
dress no I married him because I enjoy
spending time with him and I trust him
and that's what I wanted someone at work
it is right yeah so what have you had
directors yell at you and I'm sure you
have not yell Olli I don't really do any
that would warrant getting yelled at
yeah well sometimes it might even be
you're doing something wrong might be a
tie can they just say like hey whatever
you're doing is not working and I try
not to have any ego involved and I go
like oh okay
because it's not about what I think is
working for the part there is a set of
eyes that's watching this cohesive
vision of the entire movie so if they're
telling me that I'm not fitting in it's
my job to be a chameleon and fit in and
you've been able to we have to wrap up
they're telling us but you've been able
to kind of like mold yourself and go
okay and then just literally my job it's
rotate direction okay that's literally
my job well you're all you're fantastic
I mean I almost said awesome and I said
fantastic that sounds cooler and more
adult this Friday Kristen Bell and of
course on Twitter I am and not the words
the letters the letters I am Kristen
Bell yet your official Twitter it's
amazing though you got you get this
movie coming out yeah you're part of the
frozen franchise yeah the good place got
picked up yeah we start in a couple
weeks when I feel like the end of the
last season it was kind of like dreaming
right it could have also been the last
at the correct but now it's this hole
and it's going to get even crazier I
found up heaven was hell yeah crazy we
did spoiler alert yeah yeah I was
talking to somebody about helm they said
we're already in it yeah that's so bad
at closing it oh alright we're going to
break real quick and thank you for
coming wish you had more time you're a
fantastic